[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
paris schön dass sie dabei sind
willkommen den sport den hat norbert
lehmann für sich also von mir heute gab
es erstmals russisch-ukrainische
verhandlungen auf regierungsebene wir
schauen darauf wie sie liefen
eintreffen dass keine hoffnung macht das
gespräch zwischen den außenministern
russlands und der ukraine bleibt ohne
ergebnis
heftige gefechte rund um hier laut
bürgermeister klitschko ist bereits die
hälfte der bewohner aus der stadt
geflohen
und pressefreiheit in schwierigen zeiten
zur verabschiedung von zdf-intendant
blut betont bundespräsident steinmeier
die bedeutung freier berichterstattung
genau zwei wochen nach beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs auf die
ukraine kamen heute also das erste mal
der russische oder ukrainische
außenminister zu verhandlungen zusammen
allerdings ohne ergebnis es wurde sich
weder auf eine zeitweilige waffenruhe
noch auf weitere flucht korridore
geeinigt bei der außenminister traten
nach dem gespräch vor die presse
getrennt voneinander jörg brase über die
schwierigen verhandlungen
für den türkischen außenminister sind
diese bilder bereits ein diplomatischer
erfolg die amtskollegen der beiden
konfliktparteien in einem raum zum
ersten mal seit kriegsbeginn
entsprechend groß die erwartungen doch
vor allem russlands außenminister lawrow
war nicht bereit diese erwartungen zu
erfüllen wiederholte stattdessen die
bekannten vorwürfe die ukraine verfolge
eine russland feindliche politik gelenkt
von neonazis und hochgerüstet vom
formatradio
diejenigen die jetzt waffen in die
ukraine pumpen müssen sich für ihre
taten verantworten
genauso wie all jene die söldner in die
ukraine schicken diese kämpfen dort in
dem geist mit dem ultra radikale und
andere bataillone das leben in der
ukraine vergiftet haben einen weiteren
hochrangigen gesprächen zwischen den
konfliktparteien china braucht nicht
interessiert auch wenn er sie nicht
ausschließen
präsident putin sichert sich nicht herrn
see lenski zu treffen und vielleicht
gibt es eines tages die notwendigkeit
dafür aber das muss vorbereitet werden
und diese vorbereitungen finden bei den
verhandlungen in belarus stadions
austria boss enttäuschung beim
ukrainischen außenminister sein
gegenüber so kleber habe gar keine
entscheidungen treffen wollen
wir können diesen krieg nicht beenden
wenn das land das für diese aggression
diese invasion verantwortlich ist gar
kein interesse daran hat dass zu tun
so ging man auseinander ohne ergebnis
und der krieg in der ukraine geht
unvermindert weiter
mit verheerenden folgen für die menschen
im land das un menschenrechts boro hat
in den krieg bisher den tod von 549
zivilistinnen und zivilisten
dokumentiert geht jedoch von einer
deutlich höheren zahl aus weltweit hatte
der angriff gestern auf eine
geburtsklinik für entsetzen gesorgt
dabei könne es sich um ein
kriegsverbrechen handeln so eu
kommissionspräsidenten von der leyen
minuten ein haus und christian volk über
die kämpfer eine
russische panzerkolonne bei pro reli
kurz vor ihr von einem ukrainischen
drohnenangriff offenbar völlig
überrascht wir sind in eine falle
geraten meldete offizier per funk es
gibt hohe verluste bilder der
ukrainischen seite deren echtheit wir so
gut wie möglich verifiziert an
doch insgesamt kennzeichnen russische
geländegewinne tag 15 dieses krieges der
vormarsch auf kiew steht im mittelpunkt
in vielen kurorten ergreifen die
menschen die flucht
mit bussen werden einwohner von ihre
bienen und butter richtung hauptstadt
gebracht viele haben tagelang im keller
und ohne heizung verbracht
wir wollten die europäer nicht verlassen
aber wir können nicht in einer kampfzone
leben wo geschossen wird außerdem gibt
es seit einer woche keinen strom mehr
und nun auch kein gas
kiew hat sich vorbereitet militärposten
sichern die zufahrtsstraßen das
stadtzentrum so gut wie menschenleer
an vielen stellen panzersperren und
barrikaden die hälfte der bevölkerung
soll die stadt bereits verlassen haben
der präsident ruft auf durchzuhalten
sie wollen uns erniedrigen und dass wir
auf knien das brot und wasser aus den
händen dieser in masuren empfangen damit
wir nur noch nach russland gehen können
um unser leben zu retten deshalb
blockieren sieht mario pohl
die städte mario pohl und wollen nova am
asowschen meer sind seit tagen
eingekesselt und von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten die angriffe auf mario
pohl gehen unvermindert weiter die lage
der stadt ist katastrophal die
versorgung völlig zusammengebrochen auch
heute der versuch mit einem hilfskonvoi
lebensmittel in die stadt zu bringen das
war zuletzt mehrfach gescheitert
im nordosten versucht die regierung
flucht korridore einzurichten um
menschen aus den umkämpften städten
richtung wollte aber zu bringen die
stadt charkiw ist weiterhin unter
ständigen beschuss
es fallen die ganze zeit bomben und
gestern gab es eine riesige explosion im
stadtzentrum seither haben wir kein
internet mehr und auch keinen strom in
lemberg in der west ukraine treffen
immer mehr hilfsgüter ein trinkwasser
nahrungsmittel kleidung toilettenpapier
von freiwilligen helfern umgepackt und
verladen für den weitertransport in die
umkämpften gebiete
weiter heftige gefechte also katrin
eigendorf für uns in der ukraine und
keine diplomatische annäherung zwischen
russland und der ukraine bei den
verhandlungen wie wird das aufgenommen
interessanterweise ist das hier
überhaupt nicht auf enttäuschung
gestoßen die meisten menschen hier haben
das erwartet und deswegen als ich heute
hier durch die innenstadt gegangen bin
mit leuten gesprochen habe haben die nur
abgewinkt und gesagt wir hatten nicht
der erwartung dass diese verhandlungen
etwas bringen hier kann nur eins etwas
bringen dass endlich die nato den
luftraum über unserem land schließt und
dafür sorgt dass russland uns hier nicht
aus der luft mehr angreifen kann das ist
das worauf die meisten menschen hier
ihre hoffnung setzen und auf die
widerstandskraft ihrer eigenen armee und
der bevölkerung
trotzdem interessanterweise ist sie
lenski hier als kluger krisenmanager
aufgetreten und hat ja lösungen auf den
tisch gelegt hat ja ansätze geboten und
eigentlich hatten viele beobachter und
ich auch ich selber erwartet dass die
verhandlungen zumindest einen kleinen
weg öffnen einander näher zu kommen aber
das ergebnis zeigt russland ist ein
völlig unberechenbarer gesprächspartner
lang aus der ukraine katrin eigendorf
angesichts des krieges will die eu die
ukraine noch stärker unterstützen ein
baldiger eu beitritt wie von käfer hofft
aber unwahrscheinlich bei ihrem gerade
begonnenen informellen gipfel wollen die
eu staats und regierungschefinnen und
chefs aber über eine engere anbindung
der ukraine sprechen und über fragen der
sicherheit thomas weiter aus besser ein
hauch von geschichte umweht diesen eu
gipfel und das nicht nur wegen des ortes
an dem er stattfindet nach einschätzung
der 27 die sich auf schloss versailles
versammeln stellt der angriffskrieg
russlands eine tektonische verschiebung
in europas historie der g honig rennen
der krieg in der ukraine ist ein
immenses trauma das ist ein drama ein
humanitäres drama ein politisches
humanitäres und das ist sicherlich ein
element das die architektur europas
vollständig neu definieren wird
fiktionen und warum die einheit für die
einigkeit geschlossenheit die
solidarität die in den letzten wochen
miteinander praktiziert wurde ist
sicherlich von niemandem erwartet worden
aber ganz ganz wichtig damit wir eine
friedliche entwicklung ermöglichen
können die eu hat schnell sanktionen
gegen russland verhängt und die ukraine
unterstützt nun will sie die
langfristigen konsequenzen vorbereiten
als europäische länder werden wir mehr
für verteidigung ausgeben müssen die
invasion der ukraine hat die
sicherheitslage in europa verändert
um die eu wirtschaftlich robuster zu
machen müssen wir die abhängigkeit von
russischem gas abbauen
die ukraine will eben mitglied werden
hier bremsen die regierungschefs sie
erfüllen nicht die regeln
ukraine das gefühl geben dass jetzt
alles von heute auf morgen gehen würde
aber auch hier will der gipfel ein
signal senden die ukraine georgien und
moldawien sollen an die eu herangeführt
werden
um sich vor den russischen bomben und
raketen in sicherheit zu bringen haben
mittlerweile 2,3 millionen menschen ihre
heimat die ukraine verlassen der größte
teil mehr als die hälfte ist noch polen
geflohen einige dann weiter nach
deutschland knapp 96.000 einreisen hat
der bundesgrenzschutz bislang gezählt
zumeist kamen die menschen in berlin an
die kapazitäten dort sind aber erschöpft
nun soll in hannover ein neues drehkreuz
entstehen elisabeth schmidt dieses
mädchen ist so müde dass es gleich mal
aus dem zug gehoben wird einige
geflüchtete sind fast 60 stunden auf den
beinen erschöpfte mütter kinder mit
geschwollenen füßen etwa 600 menschen
von der ukraine ging es für sie nach
polen und von dort mit dem sonderzug zum
messebahnhof in hannover
ich musste meinen mann und meine große
tochter in kiew zurück lassen das war
für mich das schwierigste nicht der weg
hierher ich bin den europäern so dankbar
ich bekommen zu essen zu trinken auch
ein dach über dem kopf aber frieden wäre
mir natürlich lieber
der messe bahnhof ist das drehkreuz für
die verteilung in die bundesländer
bislang auf zuruf und noch freien
kapazitäten in hannover wird zunächst
koordiniert wer reist weiter zu
verwandten oder freunden wer weiß gerade
nicht wohin und wer benötigt
medizinische und psychologische
betreuung
die psychische belastung eines solchen
erlebnisses einer solchen vertreibung
sind natürlich wahnsinnig zumal die
familien auseinandergerissen wurden
durch die generalmobilmachung durften ja
männer nicht mitreisen hier können sie
ein bisschen zur ruhe kommen gut 2000
feldbetten stehen in den messehallen
bereit eine registrierung ist für
ukrainische staatsbürger erstmal kein
muss in der eu gilt 90 tage visafreiheit
die kommunen stellt das vor große
herausforderungen
viele kommen unkoordiniert und plötzlich
hierher wir haben auch gesundheitliche
herausforderungen allein in unserer
stadt hat jetzt drei notkaiserschnitt
die bei jungen müttern gemacht werden
mussten ob messehalle oder
privatunterkunft vielen geflüchteten ist
erstmal egal wohin hauptsache in
sicherheit irgendwo in deutschland
und heute um viertel nach acht im zdf
ein besonderer spenden abend für die
menschen in der ukraine mit markus lanz
vielen prominenten gästen und reportagen
unserer korrespondentinnen und
korrespondenten
wenn sie den geflüchteten und den
menschen loca ihnen helfen und spenden
wollen dann können sie das beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
hintergründe und entwicklungen zu dem
krieg in der ukraine haben wir für sie
natürlich auch online den liveblog mit
einem überblick über die aktuellen
geschehnisse finden sie in unserer zdf
heute
und jetzt zur wirtschaft und damit zur
zinsentscheidung der europäischen
zentralbank
der leitzins bleibt trotz der hohen
inflation bei den historisch niedrigen 0
prozent den zeitpunkt für eine mögliche
zinswende ließ ezb chefin christine lang
offen sie signalisierte aber die
milliardenschweren anleihekäufe
schneller zurückzufahren um sie dann
möglicherweise im sommer auslaufen zu
lassen das gilt als voraussetzung für
eine zinswende
kommen wir zur aktuellen corona welle
das robert-koch-institut hat bei den
infektionen einen neuen höchstwert
registriert trotzdem sollen viele
schutzmaßnahmen in zehn tagen am 20 märz
entfallen das rkw meldet 262 1752
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages das
sind 52
1079 mehr als vor einer woche
259 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kurven 19 innerhalb von 24 stunden die
sieben tage incidents liegt bei 1300
88,5
zahlreiche brücken wir in deutschland
sind marode das
bundesverkehrsministerium will daher nun
bis 2030 rund 4000 marode
autobahnbrücken verstärken oder erneuern
lassen mehrheitlich handelt es sich
dabei um bauwerke der 60er und 70er
jahre die bundesmittel sollen von 20 26
an auf zweieinhalb milliarden euro pro
jahr erhöht werden eine milliarde euro
mehr als heute hieß es nach einem
brücken gipfel auch mit vertretern und
vertreterinnen der bauwirtschaft und der
umweltschutzverbände
man sieht in russland was passiert wenn
medien nicht frei berichten können
bundespräsident steinmeier hielt daher
heute ein plädoyer für die
pressefreiheit bei der verabschiedung
des zdf intendanten thomas bellut
journalismus ist oft lebensgefährlich
aber eben auch überlebenswichtig und
zwar für uns alle für die liberale
demokratie sagte der bundespräsident und
dankte dem intendanten für seine mutige
arbeit zehn jahre lang war bellut zdf
intendant susanne gelhard berichtet
es war ein abschied mit starken
politischen akzenten der bundespräsident
persönlich war gekommen gerade in diesen
zeiten sei ihm das ein anliegen alles
kann passieren wenn menschen keinen
zugang zu informationen
kein rechter freie meinung haben
wenn menschen der wahrheit beraubte
russland führt einen brutalen
menschenverachtenden angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine
und die russische bevölkerung soll davon
nichts erfahren
thomas bellut habe sich im zdf als
journalist stets für die pressefreiheit
eingesetzt er trieb die digitalisierung
voran machte das zdf zum marktführer sie
haben das cdf schlanker und
schlagkräftiger gemacht und den aufbruch
in die digitale welt eingeleitet schon
als programmdirektor entwickelte thomas
bellut aus einem sender eine
senderfamilie jünger und frischer auch
dank der heute show die schickte zum
abschied oliver welke
thomas bellut ist der vater der satire
schiene im zdf dazu bei aus keinen
vaterschaftstest er hat sich damals
neues aus der anstalt getraut und damit
ja eine art satire kettenreaktion auf
dem lerchenberg in gang gesetzt der ich
letztlich einen großteil meiner
altersvorsorge verdanke ich habe heute
für einen norddeutschen eine sehr hohe
dosis von lob bekommen da in meiner
heimat heißt es eigentlich nicht
getadelt ist klug genug so gesehen habe
ich genossen vielen dank dafür
am dienstag übernimmt sein nachfolger
norbert hier mehr
jetzt kommen wir zum sport zu norbert
und da gab es gestern abend einen
riesenerfolg für real madrid die
königlichen besiegen nach 0 1-rückstand
das welt star ensemble von paris mit 3
zu 1 10 ins viertelfinale ein und feiern
ihren dreifach torschützen karim benzema
er ist der mann der das spiel dreht
karim benzema 3 treffer binnen 16
minuten das star ensemble von psg
dagegen wie versteinert
dieses robuste einsteigen von benzema
gegen torwart donner roma erhitzt die
gemüter noch lange nach dem spiel aber
schiedsrichter mark kelly aus den
niederlanden gibt den ausgleich für real
dadurch dreht sich das spiel wenn sie
mal nicht im abseits die führung für
real modric mit zauberhaften zuspiel der
schuss noch abgefälscht durch martin
muss eben jener marquinhos produziert
zwei minuten später einen folgenschweren
fehlpass
benzemas hattrick dadurch perfekt das
stadion in madrid ein tollhaus die
millionen truppe aus paris bleibt im
achtelfinale hängen an entfesselten
madrilenen und ihrem top stürmer
starker auftritt von benedikt doll beim
weltcup-sprint im estischen otepää der
31 jährige wird im rennen über zehn
kilometer dritter und erreicht damit in
dieser saison zum dritten mal einen
podestplatz
mit null fehlern beim schießen legt der
schwarzwälder den grundstein für sein
glänzendes abschneiden roman rees auf 5
und erik lesser auf rang sieben
komplettieren ein sehr gutes deutsches
gesamtergebnis zum er dran machen ist es
heute recht ein traum wenn es dann noch
im sie im wettkampf so gut läuft es umso
mehr spaß
weiterhin in einer eigenen klasse staub
dass der franzose gonzalo fierro mayet
der 29 jährige feierte seinen achten
saisonsieg vor dem norweger lag reiz und
ist vom gewinn des gesamtweltcups kaum
mehr zu trennen
titelverteidiger karl geiger hat bei der
skiflug-wm entwicklers und einen
ordentlichen start erwischt der 29
jährige flog auf der größten anlage der
welt 2 121 5 meter und belegte damit in
der qualifikation den sechsten rang
tagesbester österreichs weltrekordmann
stefan kraft der 230 meter schaffte
das was vom sport dankeschön eine
frostige nacht steht uns bevor aber dann
scheint morgen auf die sonne das klingt
doch gut mehr dazu gibt's gleich von
özden terli das heute-journal können sie
um 22 uhr sehen mit christian sieh was
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter mit viel sonnenschein und wenigen
wolken ging es heute durch den tag und
so wird es auch in der kommenden nacht
seien dafür liegt legt der wind aus
südost zu und wird teilweise kräftig
sein und durch dementsprechend fühlen
sich die temperaturen in der nacht noch
kälter an die bei minus sechs bis minus
8 grad liegen werden und 4 grad im
westen ja morgen wieder viel
sonnenschein einzig im südwesten kommen
hohe schleierwolken reingezogen
ansonsten aber der wind weiterhin stramm
aus südöstlichen richtungen und das bei
höchsten temperaturen von fünf grad an
der ostsee und 15 grad ganz im westen
einen schönen abend